new york times number one best-selling
author did you catch that new york times
number one date again jenny han new york
times that's selling over that would be
jenny han
she's written beloved young adult novels
like to all the boys i've loved before
and p.s i still love you her books are
published by simon schuster which by the
way is a division of our parent company
paramount global han's famous trilogy
the summer i turn pretty is now a new
series on prime video it follows belly a
teenage girl whose family stays in a
beach house every summer with her mom's
best friend and her sons conrad and
jeremiah now this summer just ahead of
her 16th birthday the boys start to
realize belly isabella
she isn't a kid anymore in this scene
belly confronts conrad for trying to
derail her first date
why couldn't you let me have this one
thing
huh
admit it you knew what you were doing
what what was i doing
me that you existed
i don't know what you're talking about
you cared where i was who i was with no
i didn't
i don't care stop lying stop being such
a baby oh and you're such an adult
you spent your saturday night crashing
my first date for fun
jenny han looking lovely in oscar de la
renta thank you very much drop the
microphone miss on i don't think that
clip really does it justice the dynamics
between your characters by the way can i
just say i'm team conrad i'll just say
it
definitely you are yes i am
and i didn't even waver i really waiver
i got very concerned as i was watching
how it's going to turn out on team
conrad
but i love the title uh i feel let's see
the summer
the summer i turned pretty i love that
title jenny what does it mean to me it
means um
stepping into your own power
uh i think it's a moment of like coming
of age of growing up and you know
feeling feeling yourself feeling good
good yeah yourself yeah ellie certainly
does that and the whole time i'm reading
it i'm thinking is it loosely based on
you or how you felt or what you did i
said i think the moments of um
agony and embarrassment
um i can draw from my own life but uh i
would say that i was thinking about you
know i think girlhood in general
yeah the soundtrack's amazing the other
thing you don't get from that clip is
that it's shot on this beautiful beach
in north carolina uh and the soundtrack
is incredible it's got taylor swift it's
got olivia rodrigo it's got cardi b
uh i gotta imagine the budget for all
that was a big time budget like why was
it so important to get the right songs
at the right time to me i think that
there's always like a song of summer um
you think back to a moment and you
remember like the song and the feeling
and i wanted people to watch the show
and feel nostalgic and have a memory of
something and kind of hit into i think
that pulse point
of being young and in love
you know gail talked about your
inspiration maybe it's taken from your
life but you also say that taylor swift
t swift was a large she she loomed large
in your writing process tell me about
that i mean i've been a fan for years as
i was writing the books i was listening
to her music i was listening to fearless
i almost dedicated it
yeah the second book to her because
yeah she just has a way i think with her
storytelling ability i just tap so
quickly into emotions that i need to get
to when i'm writing um
that it was a big like my biggest wish
was to get one of her songs on the show
and because i knew it meant a lot to the
fans yeah they had been begging me for
years and so that was like the best gift
that i could give them yes well i
definitely it's true that the the the
music that taylor swift writes actually
dovetails with with your work in other
words the stories that she tells about
young love about rejection about fear
are echoed in your writing i think i
think that um she understands
um young womanhood in a way and also um
love stories that i'm that means a lot
to me as well i'm fascinated by you
jenny because you were told years ago
that by publishers that you know people
won't read stories about asian americans
and about asian american families at
first belly wasn't an asian girl true
that's true um and then when you were
told that did it hurt your feelings did
you believe it i think it didn't even
really hurt my feelings because it was
just kind of so matter of fact
um is that why belly is white in the
original novel in the original novel you
know i had tried to sell a book with an
asian main character before
this one and people weren't really
interested in it i think the main the
thing i would hear is like we already
have like a book with um an asian we
already have one we have one
and so you know i thought the summary
turned pretty it felt like a story that
i hoped would have a certain kind of
like effervescence to it that people
could could lock on to and then after
that i did to all the boys and i was
able to kind of write my own ticket um
once i had garnered like trust from an
audience that might not have picked up a
book with someone that didn't look like
them no jenny said they're going to be
some changes
i like that and even on the cover that
you have belly because you said you
don't really see asian american uh
characters on covers yes and you know so
first it was well to all the boys was
the first book um to hit the best seller
list with an asian girl on the cover and
even with my first book um it was
important to me put my picture on the
back of it because at first they were
like we don't really need but it wasn't
really done at that time and i thought
well young i want other young asian
women to see that and think it's
possible yeah what a staggering success
to start writing have the books go to
number one and now to have a big time
series and season two has already been
approved right yeah
yeah or production we're uh yeah i'm
about to leave today and you delayed for
us i deleted i'm supposed to go
yesterday
and you're telling your friends go on
tick-tock and do what what do you want
to do um go on take talk and i don't
know they're still they're making such
amazing content about the show that to
me it means a lot just as a creator to
see all the stuff they make so are you
team conrad or team oh my gosh gail no
no no i'm team belly
all right
whatever she wants
i'm team belly too i got to say very
often
billy too but i'm also team conrad yeah
but the big team to be team belly you
got to be on one of the all right and
and i love the line between the moms too
i love i love that story line i want
everything to be all right there
so oh and for the olds out there it's
the same beach where they shot dawson's
creek i know i know john just got to go
but you know what jenny i was just going
to watch one episode just to get a feel
of it and then i ended up watching the
whole deal oh i'm so honored oh no it's
it's good it's really good it's amazing
and tony said he's going to watch it
yeah i've actually resisted it's a long
story but i'm gonna watch it with my
older kids because i think it'll bring
up all kinds of important conversations
okay well there you go they will
congratulations
so much
love your work cheering you on cheering
you on keep it coming